what is wrong with US policy towards
Cuba well the bears no relation to
reality we've done this for 49 years
we've hoped that we could bring the
Cuban regime down economically and if we
couldn't do it after the Soviets pulled
out and we're certainly not going to do
it today so the Cuban economy isn't that
great but it's certainly better than it
was for them you know in the mid 90s I
think that the default should be freedom
and just allow Americans to travel allow
Americans to trade allow goods and
commerce to go there it's not a
guarantee that it would work but it's
certainly when you're going to have a
default it should be freedom why why
hasn't it Oh a number of reasons one you
have members of Congress and
administration's that just don't want to
admit that they've been wrong and they
think just a little more time and it
will work members of Congress have had
this pattern of voting year after year
after year to uphold the embargo or to
tighten it and it's tough to say I'm
wrong let's do a different policy but
then too we have a whole cottage
industry in Miami in particular build up
around this policy we spend probably
between 50 and 60 million dollars a year
mostly in South Florida radio and TV
Marty grants to universities to study
the topic to nonprofit organizations to
smuggle food and whatnot down there and
it just as an industry that just
Foster's itself and so there's a lot
vested in this current policy
unfortunately I've said that will never
have rational farm policy as long as
campaigns begin in Iowa and as long as
they seemingly end in Florida it's tough
to have rational Cuba policy but I think
we're close frankly there are a lot of
people on Capitol Hill that are looking
for an excuse to have a more rational
policy and having Fidel out of the
picture may give them that excuse even
if it's his brother in charge and even
if things haven't changed that much in
Cuba I think there's a realization that
we have to do something different
why are you interested in you know I
just always bothered that we have as
Republicans we have an inconsistent
foreign policy we preach engagement in
commerce and contact in China or Vietnam
or North Korea but then we say Cuba no
it's a different story there you can't
do it and it's it's bothered me and my
constituents are told you can't travel
there it's simply wrong every American
should go to Cuba not just because it
would be good for Cubans it'd be good
for Americans be good to see what
happens when government controls the
means of production and controls the
economy and controls healthcare you'd
see it a little different than the
Michael Moore saw down there and so
every American should have that
experience as well I think you'd be a
greater appreciation for capitalism
after you come back